هل سألت ما إذا كنت أعتقد أن هذه الحرب
ستستمر طويلاً لا لأن أه لم
تبدأ هذه الحرب وأنا متأكد من أنه لا
يوجد أوكراني واحد يعرف ما
ستكون عليه هذه الحرب وما هي المأساة التي
ستجلبها إلى كل منزل في منطقتنا.  البلد
لأنني أكرر أننا لم نبدأ هذه
الحرب ولكن المجتمع الأوكراني المتحدة
وأظهر أنه مستعد لما
كان للأسف مثل هذه المأساة أظهر
أنه جاهز لهذه التحديات
لقد تأثرت حقًا
بقوة أمة واحدة وأعجبني
سرعة استجابة أوروبا
والعالم بأسره والمجتمع الدولي بأسره
الذين احتشدوا حول أوكرانيا
لهذا التحدي
السيدة الأولى
ما الذي يحفزك على الاستيقاظ في
الصباح كيف تشعر أنك
تحملت هذه الحرب
جيدًا ، شكرًا لك إنها كبيرة  السؤال الذي
يغطي العديد من مجالات حياتي وما الذي
يساعدني على الاستيقاظ في الصباح ، أنا
بالتأكيد كما قلت ، إنه مثال زوجي ،
أعلم أنه إذا استمر ،
فيجب أن أتحمل إذا بدأ اليوم ،
يا سيدي الرئيس ، استمر في القتال الذي يجعلني
أستمر في المضي قدمًا ، ما هي حالة
حسن والمعركة الوشيكة
لاستعادة حسن
، حان الوقت ليلا ،
أنت تعلم أن هذا سؤال خطير
للغاية وسأكون صريحًا معك وسأحاول
الإجابة عليه بطريقة  هذا لا يعطيك
إجابة لكي تكون صريحًا
، فهذه العمليات العسكرية المخطط لها تمت
مناقشتها في دائرة صغيرة ولكن بعد ذلك
يتم تنفيذها في صمت وأريد حقًا
أن يكون لدي مفاجأة غير
سارة للعدو وليس شيئًا
يستعدون له  لذلك أود أن أعتذر ،
ولكن على أي حال ، فإن شعبنا
وعامة الناس يحتاجون إلى معرفة أننا نعمل
على بعض الخطوات الجادة للغاية ذات
النتائج الإيجابية لمواطني
أوكرانيا وجميع المجتمعات التي
تدعم السلام في أوكرانيا ،
هل هذا صحيح  أنك قلت للرئيس
بايدن عندما عرضوا إخلائك
في البداية أنك قلت إنني لست
بحاجة إلى رحلة ، فأنا بحاجة إلى ذخيرة ،
نعم هذا صحيح ، لم يتغير شيء ، فأنت
تعلم أن إجابتي لا تزال هي نفسها
ما هي القوة التي تحصل عليها من كل س
إذا كان بإمكاني
ذلك ، فهذا هو حبي وهذا هو أفضل صديق لي ،
لذا فإن طاقتي أردت أن
أجيب على سؤالك في
البداية عندما أخبرتك أورلاندو وكأنها
أعدت الإفطار
للأطفال في الصباح وأعدت الملابس
وما إلى ذلك.  وما الذي أردت أن أخبرك به
ولكن ليس لدي مثل هذه الاحتمالية ، لذلك
لا أحد يعطيني وجبة الإفطار في
الصباح وأعني أنها
فترة صعبة للغاية أريد
أن أسألك عنها لأنكما تجلسان معي هنا
في  في الوقت الذي كان فيه الأمريكيون
انتخابات تجريبية مهمة ،
يبدو أنها ليست موجة ضخمة
ولكن أتساءل عما إذا كنت قلقًا من
أنه قد يكون هناك إجهاد من المانحين في الغرب
ربما في الولايات المتحدة
بسبب الضغوط الاقتصادية ربما إذا قال بعض
الجمهوريين لا  المزيد من الشيكات الفارغة
لأوكرانيا ، لقد كان لديك الكثير من
الزوار الأمريكيين هنا في هذه الأيام القليلة الماضية
من الإدارة العليا ،
هل أنت متأكد من دعم أمريكا المستمر
ودعم أوروبا المستمر
نود حقًا الحصول على الدعم ،
خاصة مقدار الدعم
للبقاء كما هو والحصول على هذا الدعم المشترك
من المجتمع الأمريكي وقبل كل شيء
دافعي الضرائب في الولايات المتحدة لأنه في نهاية اليوم
هذا ليس مال الحكومة
ولكن المال
و  ثانيًا ، نحن ممتنون
للدعم من الحزبين ، ونود
حقًا أن يبقى هذا الدعم من الحزبين
بعد الانتخابات لأنه نعم
كانت هناك هذه الرسائل
المختلطة في وسائل الإعلام الأمريكية وخاصة من
الجانب الجمهوري
، ومن المهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا
الحفاظ على هذا المستوى  من الدعم
لأن الدعم الأمريكي يرسل
إشارة قوية للغاية وله
تأثير أيضًا على مقدار الدعم
القادم من دول الاتحاد الأوروبي
وبعض الدول خارج الاتحاد الأوروبي وكذلك
كلما دعمتنا الولايات المتحدة
مالياً ثم تنضم أوروبا إلى هذا
الدعم كذلك